Oh Boy!
it's been a busy time;
lot of stuff has happened;
got myself a bad haircut. I thought I'd do an update vlog,
'cause there's a lot of stuff I wanna talk about
so please sit down and listen
and shut the fuck up
we did the Cringemas livestream with revelmode
it was so much fun, did you watch?
let's do a highlight
Jack in video: "wait"
Mark: "wait"
Jack: "Did we-"
Jack: "WE HIT OUR GOAL!!"
*WHQODKASDLjlsjCHHDJSxkjoDKOASK*
so we raised 1 million 3 hundred-
OVER 1 million 3 hundred thousand dollars
towards RED which is a charity
based to stop AIDS
also, thanks to youtube who donated $100,000
and the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation which matched
a million dollars
I'm very proud of that and I'm proud of everyone involved
but also, we gained A 50 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS! :D
it happened all at the same time, I didn't- it was so weird
the craziest weekend
Jesus Christ
50 MILLION
I know it's cliche as hell for me to say this-
but I never thought we would hit that number
part of me is like:
"y'know, it's just a number-
really all I care about is that you guys watch my videos and-
that's what really matters."
bUT AT THE SAME TIME
MILLION
FUCK
YEAH
SUCK MY DI-
damn did I go fast- it went fast
it happened at that same time as my channel was dying
thank god
think about that if your channel is dying just pull a PR stunt and you're-
you're fine again
'cause it looks like now youtube fixed my channel. I don't know what happened
I wanna talk about that as well
there was a lot that I wanted to say in the video where said I was gonna delete my channel
or when I was supposed to do it
I didn't really get the chance 'cause I just-
that video needed to be funny
otherwise everyone would kill me
but basically
would I delete my channel?
have I thought about it?
ser- in a serious way?
yes
I have
like I said before
it's just numbers
and I really do care about that you guys are- you guys just watch my videos
that's the main important thing for me
I know it's like a meme that youtube is a job and we're all just overpaid and we shouldn't complain about anything
WHICH IS TRUE
I think being number one on youtube-
or being a youtuber in general-
it comes with a price
that is kind of hard to explain
without just sounding like;
"oh boohoo your life is so hard"
I don't think there's a point for me to even get into it but
it is true
and a lot of times I feel like it would be nice
to just be a normal channel
y'know
I have a huge amount of respect of what- for what I do
I wouldn't just throw that all away lightly
y'know even though it might not seem like it I-
I really care about every single video I make
I make sure it's the best it can be
I do daily content after all so y'know there's-
only so much you can do with that
I take it very, very seriously
I think a lot of people don't realize that because I have this weird silly swedish
guy persona or I'm just an idiot
which is also half true y'know it's an extension
of my personality
just know when I talk about like this
I'm not really usually being serious
which also seems like ANOTHER THING that people don't fucking understand
the main thing about- that a lot of people- the- the media especially
didn't seem to understand about the deletion video
was that
I wasn't complaining just for me.
it wasn't me just saying, "oh youtube I am not making enough money, fuck you."
I thought I was standing up for
not just myself but
everyone else on the platform
'cause something clearly changed and youtube is turning against it
and we can't really do much
else but to raise our voices about it
people might say "ok well pewdiepie he's- he's got a good living" wha-
what do you think youtube is? do they just have the right to screw everyone over? I don't think so
I don't think their, their intention is to do that by the way
my point was more like-
"I need to stand up for this,
this is an issue that needs to be addressed"
but I- apparently I can't do that without sounding like
*OH-HOH-HOH*
*HUNNGH*
to people
that's- that's how I took the medias
taking my response
it's really stupid
really
un, irresponsible I think
I'm not the most responsible as well so I probably shouldn't talk
so far I have not gotten a decent update or answer on what had happened
I haven't got,
uh, gotten an answer on what is going on
no one has I think
really gotten a-
a decent answer
which I'm kinda frustrated about
I-I know I'm gonna talk to them soon again
and I hope I will have a- a better answer
if anything there's- for youtube to learn from this is that they need to have a better dialog
with their users
they need to
have
less
just
specific dialog with different youtubers
they need to talk to all the youtubers not just the top guys
and if there's anything us youtubers need to learn
or creators is that we need to be more clear with what
we're saying- I think a lot
"the rants" or the "youtube, fuck youtube" videos
do they really help?
I don't know
complaining about youtube has just become a meme
I can imagine it's hard for youtube to see all this and be like
"ok well
what is really true?
what is really just a rant and what is really going on?"
it seems so messy
and I think it's not going- going anywhere
I'm just trynna criticize us really
I don't wanna just shit on youtube
whatever youtube's goal is
I support it
ok, I'm not trynna
turn my back on it
but I do think if they talked to the users what it is
they will get there faster ok, just tell us
talk to us
I've been getting tired of saying that
now
the media
the media's reaction to me deleting the video was the absolute dumbest thing
I have ever seen
and I- don't get me wrong I don't hate the media
not all- some- most of it
ok most of it
my message got destroyed
whatever I said in that video
they took whatever piece they wanted from that
and it was ridiculous
I made this other video that was very articulate
and very clear what the problem was
but no one talked about that video they just took the first video I did
which was just like half satire, half comedy
and they just took pieces out of that
which is ridiculous
so that's why I really enjoy that video where I make fun of them a little bit
'cause it was so stupid. and to put it in perspective
we raised over a million dollars to charity
not a single one posted about that
not a single one of those article mentioned it
even mentioned it
I think that says a lot
I'm not saying they're obligated to talk about whatever we raised for charity but
it's interesting how it never even got mentioned
I think that just says a lot about how media works
y'know
too many times
I've been a punching bag
uh for the whole situation- for for what they're doing
anyway
so I was glad how it turned out
I hope- did you want me to delete my channel?
are you disappointed now?
I AM SO SORRY
OH BOOHOO POODIEPIE DIDN'T DELETE HIS CHANNEL
maybe you need another hobby then ( like doing cc's :( )
I'm glad a lot of people were happy that I wasn't deleting it at least ( me :) )
I'm really glad I don't have to answer the question now
"wai- are you really gonna do it pewds!? are you really gonna do it!?"
I also wanna just take the time to just say thanks to everyone involved in the cringemas
charity livestream with revelmode
I wanna thank Mark for flying over and Amy, it was really fun hanging out with those guys
a bit more, every time that I meet Mark I just meet him for one day so I never really got a chance to hang out with him
but it was really fun
I really enjoyed it
uh Jack,
and Signe for flying over as well of course
so fun to meet those guys
it's just- we had a great time
UHM OF COURSE PJ
for helping out the charity
he's a beautiful man ( true )
don't like- I don't really like him though
*HUH-HUAH*
( I'm kidding )
and Emma of course. apparently people were mean to her in the comments, so-
Emma, don't listen to anyone, you're great :)
you're so good :))))))))
Uhm, thanks for everyone that worked on that charity and helped out
I'm really proud that we managed to hit our donation goal
AND THANKS TO EVERYONE THAT DONATED ♥
it was amazing!
it was really cool to see it
these are the things I'm really proud of
and i'm very happy i'm able to do these, uhm, positive things with what i do
NOW
MOVING FORWARD: WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN??
well- I'm not deleting
well actually I aM
AT A 100 MILLION WE'RE DELETING THIS CHANNEL!!1!
100 MILLION
CAN WE DO IT!?
A HUNDRED MILLION!
the haters better start subscribing now
'cause otherwise we'd run out of people
I feel like I'm barely getting-
I'm just getting started
I think I will keep doing youtube as long as I feel like I have more to give
and I really feel like I still have that in me
uh I think that's the most important-
important thing for me, and-
I know Casey Neistat recently stopped vlogging and in a way I understand, now, why...
'cause he said he wasn't because he was tired- he was more, like, creatively exhausted
I think doing the same thing
over and over it really wears you out and I think that's why it's almost like you get a different pewdiepie each year
uh that's why I've changed so much
because that's how it's interesting and fun for me
and I really still enjoy it that way
um, so
I'm not planning to go anywhere ( good )
but I enjoy the fact that you guys thought I was ;)
it was cute ;))))))
other than that
thank you so much for supporting what I do it really means a lot
especially when so much-
I don't wanna say hate but-
negativity seems to be, wanna, surround what I do a lot of the times
despite the fact that I don't think I do that much bad, okay-
it's just how it is I guess
so thank you ♥
it means a lot
it really does
and stay awesome
I'll see you
in the next video
*brofist for the bro ARMY*
~ARMY ♥